on a eu un texte qui était mal ficelé
avec de nombreuses questions qui sont
restées sans réponse de la part du
gouvernement est ce qui fait qu un texte
qu'on devait étudier en l'espace de
quelques heures
hier s'est terminée ce matin à 5h30 5h45
du matin et avec une très très faible
majorité en faveur de l'adoption du
texte
il y avait une vraie plus de nombreuses
questions qui n'ont pas été que pas su
trouver réponse de la part du
gouvernement on peut penser à la
question du délai de la mise en
application de ces demandes de passes
sanitaire par exemple pour les jeunes
les jeunes qui ont subi de plein fouet
la crise du coc vide et qui n'ont pas pu
faire vacciner qui ont été les derniers
à pouvoir se faire vacciner et qui même
en respectant le calendrier de
vaccination se verrait interdit de
certaines activités
s'ils ne sont pas testés négatifs alors
même qu'ils sont dans la volonté d'être
vaccinés par manque de doses ou parce
qu'ils ont fait que la première dose
c'est donc là on a demandé un d'étendre
le délai ça a été rejetée par le
gouvernement nous avons également mis en
avant le fait que ce n'est pas aux
restaurateurs de demander de contrôler
les identités des personnes qui rentrent
de contrôler les passes les certificats
de vaccination de test négatif des
clients qui viennent y prendre un verre
mais c'est une un pouvoir que sartre
régalien qui vaut aujourd'hui serait
donné aux restaurateurs mais refusé dans
tous les cas aux policiers municipaux
ont trouvé que c'était quand même un peu
fort de café et la même façon on
trouvait que demander le passe à
lithaire sur les terrasses étaient
parfaitement excessifs puisqu'on sait
que quand on est en extérieur les
aérosols se diffuse beaucoup moins le
canton mais en intérieur et qu' il était
possible d'aménager des possibilités de
rester sans pas sanitaire auprès des
cafetiers sur des terrasses auprès les
ennemis des groupes d'amis